Girls are way nicer than guys.
At least, that’s what the headlines say.
The headlines actually say a lot of extreme
things when it comes to stories about science.
Whether they’re writing about mass extinctions
or just how unhealthy it is to eat french
fries, there can be a lot of noise.
So we made this show, Science or Fiction,
to take a look behind the headlines and find the facts.
Can science show that women are nicer than
men?
Sure, there are nursery rhymes and anecdotes
about women being the kinder, gentler sex,
but the news makes it seem like there’s
actual data to back up that belief.
So is it true?
Scientists have actually been studying the
behavioral differences between men and women
for a long time, like some sort of bad 1980s stand-up comedian.
Comedians, they’re the worst, right?
Specifically, there’s been a good bit of
research about whether women exhibit more
prosocial behavior than men.
And guys, hate to say it, the data doesn’t
look good for us.
Studies going back to the 1980s have found
that women are more kind, considerate, comforting,
helpful and are more likely to share than
men.
And this new study attempts to back all that
up by examining the way the pleasure centers
in our brain respond to behaving in an altruistic manner.
Now, the researchers ran their study a couple
of different ways.
First, they used drugs.
Not those kind of drugs.
They used a dopamine inhibitor and a placebo.
Participants were first given the placebo,
and then presented with a hypothetical situation
where they had to decide between keeping a
large sum of money for themselves or splitting
it with another person.
Women went with splitting the money way more
than men did, 51% to 40%.
They then repeated that task while taking
a dopamine inhibitor, basically cutting off
the chemical reward your brain would be giving
you for doing something nice.
In that case, things were more evenly split
with 45% of women going for the prosocial
money-splitting option as opposed to 44% for men.
Then the researchers did something really
cool.
They used brain scans to analyze activity
in the brain’s striatum, which is where
our reward system plays out.
And, as expected, women showed more activity
in the striatum when they decided to split
the cash, whereas men had more activity when
they kept all of it for themselves.
Or, in other words, when women did the nice thing, their brains were rewarded by
upping their dopamine levels, where guys got the same reward for doing the more selfish thing.
Guys, not looking good here.
Now, there are some critics of the study.
They point out that in the placebo trial,
only 51% of the women choosing the selfless
act doesn’t exactly make them all overwhelmingly
prosocial.
And as for the brain scan part of the study?
The data was pooled from two different groups that did not use the same type of brain scanner
and were asked to perform slightly different
tasks.
Which isn’t really ideal for compiling data to come up with one conclusion.
And there’s one criticism of the study that
even its authors agree with.
Researchers point out that it is hard to say
just how much of an impact society and gender
roles play on women being kinder than men.
This actually comes up in those older studies,
too.
If we actively raise women to be kinder and
more compassionate than men, it makes sense
that this would affect the outcome of a study
like this.
Of course, other researchers have tried to
account for these factors by comparing studies
on kindness from countries with less gender equality to those with a more egalitarian society.
And the results, pretty surprising.
A study in 2009 found that women in societies
that had more equal gender roles were even
more likely to be kinder and  more selfless than
men.
Guys, I know that’s just one study but,
man, it’s not looking good for us.
So these headlines might be a bit simplistic,
but they’re actually pretty consistent with
the data we’ve got on the situation, gender
roles aside.
Guys are meaner, but who gets sicker?
Find out in this video here.
And guys, I know what you’re thinking.
We’re not all jerks!
We can be nice!
Well, here’s your chance to prove it, tell us about something nice you did in the comments.
And women, the guys may need help, so please leave some of your stories in there, too.
Don’t forget to subscribe and be sure to
come back to Seeker for more videos.